[Music]
foreign
of Ted lasso has you feeling hungry for
similar titles and also biscuits they
just look so yummy on screen here are
five more like this worth checking out
after three certified fresh Seasons it's
looking like the end has come for the
Apple TV plus comedy Ted lasso and I am
not ready for it
bad blood and cry oh
I think it's going to be okay friends
because with shows about football both
soccer and the other kind plus all the
heartfelt comedies you can handle we
have lasso together the perfect list and
that has been my best pun yet starting
with our brand new pick Angel City this
three-part docu series from HBO
showcases the la-based professional
women's soccer team Angel City that was
co-founded by Oscar winner Natalie
Portman in 2020 proving that SARS like
Ryan Reynolds and Rob mceleni and Will
Ferrell aren't the only ones that can be
in the soccer business now this one not
only tells the story of how they started
a franchise from scratch and became get
this the largest majority female
ownership group in Pro Sports but it
also lets us in on the drama with
players and coaches on and off the field
Natalie has said that she was inspired
by her son's love of the Women's World
Cup and I'm right there with you kid and
she felt compelled to contribute to some
of the cultural changes happening in
women's sports and it's her involvement
in the soccer club and the series she's
also an executive producer that has
early reviews looking very positive so
if you're kicking around the idea of
giving this one a shot all you'll need
need is Max formerly known as HBO Max
and a few hours of free time
we're gonna win we're gonna lose we're
gonna have difficult moments we're going
to elevate the sport and show how
valuable it truly is
our audience pick this week is Netflix's
the English game so this historical
miniseries is also about soccer players
only this one takes us back to the 1870s
and basically tells the story of how
soccer AKA football came to be in
England now the English game was
developed by Julian fellows who created
Downton Abbey and includes plenty of
real people as characters and real
events but of course with the drama
amped up a little bit now this one has a
high audience score at 84 but critics
actually didn't think it was a touchdown
I mean big goal in the net but the
consensus from critics does point out
that the show's quote Love of the Game
is likely to elicit a rise out of fans
but seriously no rioting just under five
hours is what it'll take you to watch
this one on Netflix and then go ahead
and give yourself some college credits
for taking a history class too
bigger than football bigger than any of
us this is your dream Focus remember
that
flying in as our under the radar pick is
the comedy series hectorous this funny
British show has a heartfelt side too
much like Ted lasso and it comes from
Creator Mackenzie crook who also Stars
alongside Toby Jones now the Pair play
friends who share a passion for metal
detecting and experience degreed
betrayal and other drama that pretty
much goes along with trying to land that
one big score that will turn them into
detecting Legends along with three 100
fresh seasons on the Tomato Meter
detectoris has Unearthed multiple Awards
and plenty of Praise all around and
critics say that the show is quote
Pleasant hilarity is a wealth of
emotional riches and my new life goal is
officially to be pleasantly hilarious
now you'll need about 10 hours to
discover and dig up this show after
which you're totally gonna price out
metal detectors on Amazon or at least I
did but you metal detectors this is a
metal detector we are metal detectors
wow outrageous tossing one pretty deep
as our throwback pick this week is
Friday Night Lights now it stars like
Kyle Chandler and Connie Britton leading
the way this hit series focuses on the
small town of Dillon Texas where winning
football championships is pretty much
top priority this show was inspired by a
book and subsequent film and developed
by Peter Berg the show would show was
also known for its great young cast
members helping launch the careers of
future stars like Michael B Jordan
Journey smullet Taylor Kitsch and Jesse
plemons now three of the show's five
fresh seasons are at 100 on the Tomato
Meter and critics love it for quote
offering a realistic glimpse into small
town life and the social issues that
accompany it you'll need to drop a play
for just under 56 hours of time to get
through this whole series and then
you'll be able to finish the line when
someone says to you Clear Eyes Full
Hearts it is Friday night and Voodoo
madness has put its spell on the Lone
Star State and 16 000 people have
gathered together to witness the debut
of Superstar Phenom Ray Boone
and finally our editor's pick this week
is the hilarious Apple TV Plus show
shrinking this series was created by
Jason Siegel along with Bill Lawrence
who co-created Ted lasso and Brett
Goldstein who appeared in and helped
write Ted lasso right of course is the
infamous Roy Kent now if you think that
Ted lasso expertly combines the humor
and heart this show might even do it
better and with a little more realism so
Jason Siegel also stars in shrinking as
a grieving therapist who starts telling
his clients exactly what he's thinking
he's joined by people like Harrison Ford
and Jessica Williams among others with
each person bringing their own memorable
moments a certified fresh for a season
was a good start as shrinking continues
to grow
so funny and the consensus from critics
is that quote Siegel and Ford's
sparkling turns make these characters
Worth close analysis shrinking actually
has been renewed for a second season but
in the meantime you can actually watch
the first in about six hours and trust
me you'll be shocked at the amount of
times that you literally LOL I'm worried
about you getting
grieving here
stop you're doing sad face this is just
face
I have resting dead wife face all right
my friends that's it and I'd say we
managed to team you up with some pretty
great picks don't you think be sure to
let us know what you're currently
streaming in the comments and check back
here for more recommendations based on
all the shows that you love right here
on Rotten Tomatoes more like this I'm
Nas Perez I'm blonde this week and I'll
see you later
[Music]
thank you